Chicago Illinois o doing four shows out
there this week do yourself a favor
couple of ticks left scoop them up grab
the squad and come see the boys yeah
baby then we're going to be in
Minneapolis Madison Milwaukee Sacramento
T show there San Francisco San Jose
Washington DC then we're ending it
ending the Year big at the Filmore in
Philadelphia two shows limited tickets
there peace yeah welcome to another
exciting edition of are you
garbage the show where you find out if
your favorite comedians are classy
individuals or absolute trash now here
are your hosts Kevin Ryan and H
Foley hey everybody out there and
welcome back to everybody's new favorite
podcast this is R you garbage it's that
little show we sit down with your
favorite comedians and we find it at the
gr it to be classy yeah to just a big
old piece of trash trash trash trash I'm
your host H fley coming out at y on a
chilly day out back here with toies in
the new edition I don't know what's
going on with the heat if she didn't pay
it or what the space heaters out baby
where's the kerosene when you need it
freezing in here shivering in here dude
my co-host is coming at you from across
the table he is the CEO of R you garbage
wearing a lovely blouse today give it up
for KJ Kevin James Ryan everybody
nothing on that Forever 21 Speckles how
you spe speckled Eon speckled blouse
what up gang thanks for tuning in as as
always please make sure you R you
subscribe on iTunes full video available
on YouTube as you know those numbers are
true cooking and obviously the greatest
website of all time I got to tell any of
you guys out there
www.patreon.com you garbage yeah go over
there I'm talking 1.9 bajillion hours of
content over there Pat pending check it
the Freak Out do you get the skirt that
goes with that too mhm the the no but a
bomb came with that
joke was that buy one get one bomb or
what are we doing over here have a nice
quick shout out to our producer boogo
bombs for the big man Everything Must Go
extraordinaire he's the magic man he
makes us all look good he works the ones
the twos the threes and the fours he
crosses the te's and he dots the eyes
give it up for Deone MC scuffins Toby
McMullen everybody what up boys what up
T-Bone listen I'm a red-blooded American
right sure you know born and bred here
uh I I I salute the flag when I wake up
just like every other one here but I got
to tell you those Canadians have the
best chip known to man The all dress
ruffle is Unstoppable it ain't bad it's
all right that's about
it other than that you're birdie steak
you had to ah what's up with those
heaters up there for the love of God I
was Behind Enemy I thought I bought two
mini discs dude they handed it to me
they look like they look like video game
packages they gave it to me and and I
dude I was like I'm like do you have
marel lights he's like they'd be marel
smooth I'm like buddy D they saying cool
Jazz over here give give me a good
American heater yeah T-Bone was singing
the old USA Praises when he got back
across that border that I kissed my I
kissed the ground baby shout out to
Toronto what a fun time fun weekend up
there uh I got a little thing speaking
of speaking of live shows uh I think
it's very funny we're doing you know uh
we're doing two large shows uh in
Philadelphia to end this tour yes we are
20th and 21st tickets still available
for the 20s scoop them up now cuz
they're going quick they're going quick
it's a [__] huge venue it's crazy
it's [__] the the Filmore we and
we're doing two man it's funny the
amount of DMS messages text emails
people knocking on my door looking for
money looking for Ticky wikies
everybody's coming out of the dude my
brother had me I like I need 30 I'm like
30 I I sent him the link to Ticket
Master buddy get in line what are I got
to move some ticket I got I got got the
same thing all a sudden nobody know how
to use a website I know I know well how
do you get them how I'm like I just saw
you at the Eagles game how'd you get
them
tickets I can breaking my stuff I know
you're not friends with Jaylen Herz I'll
tell you that your brother don't play on
that team not my mom do I have tickets
can I how do you get tickets sh it's
crazy I I said the piece I got you and
that's it no plus one I'm getting
demands on seating dude that's another
thing we up in the balcony is there a
family and friend it's not the Kentucky
Derby you think you're in the owner's
box Johnny Filmore see my budy shout out
to Deli I love you he's like yeah how do
I what he's asking me about the layout
he's like your section B good I'm like
dude I don't [__] know like I'm like
I don't know dude it ain't the garden
bro because is section B Road 19 or they
good SE is that word the chicks
herette I go I go I don't know dude I go
I got I I'll get you C go what do you
need uh I got what do you need just two
I I'll get you I'll get you two that's
it I'll get you two goes he goes he goes
cool I'll venmo you tomorrow I'm like
I'm not I'm like keep you I'm not taking
your venos selling Black Market ticks
that's a toty job that's good you know
they're good family members when they
just get the tickets and then throw it
in your face later that's what I respect
that's the Danny Ryan move dud
everywhere we've been he's been bringing
it up to [__] twist the knife at me
which I respect I I respect a good face
throwing boy pay for parking parking
talking about I wanted to tell you this
I had a weird thing happened to me the
other
day you can really shift the gear big
guy I'm in my room I'm getting
changed this is like 1970s late night
talk show I right am in my room it's all
dude it's also you're either here or in
your room if we're being
honest there's not a whole lot so I was
on Safari I did a couch sometimes just
in your room it's more comfortable okay
plus my cpat machine's right there so if
I want to take napnap I just slip on the
mask and okay I've been sleeping great I
don't know what it is I've been sleeping
fantastic deep deep sleeps dreaming all
kinds of crazy stuff it's been fun I
feel like I'm in like another world
sounds riveting I've really been
remembering my dreams too reminds me I
had a couple of Bones to pick with you
this is Lady Lady blouse this is like
that this is like that Seinfeld when
they get the MV grou and set it's Kramer
and Newman you're like I switched to wax
beans I can barely tell the difference
if I change the did you ever do we need
sweep swe here did you ever do wax beans
when you were a kid I don't know what
they are they're the gold ones gold yeah
they're gold you have green beans we
were all cans when I was a kid yeah
there were I don't know I don't know
when we got fresh vegetables dude I no I
we still don't it was all canned this is
the apocalypse at the Foley household
you have to be a chef to have fresh
green beans no no the Frozen are for the
for the casserole yeah you she would
break out the fresh ones somebody had to
die to get that [__] yeah I didn't see
or Easter Sunday or something oh my
mom's green bean C n's green bean cast
oh my God was canned I love the cans
they they were canned beans I think so
that's what every recipe calls
for yeah two can crazy we would do but
you want to know the big rub the people
the [__] the canned people are the
ones going these are the recipes use the
canned ones that's that's where W it's
all big cans that's big beans big beans
is in on that those Farmers Farmers
could read or right that's the bean
Lobby it's the Green Giant with the
giant money they're thr yeah it was
either Frozen or canned and we did we we
were on a big wax bean kick for a long
time to the yellow ones dude I remember
a little bit of butter oh now would you
eat that when you were a kid or no well
my mom is on paper avidly not liking
beans so she never gave us beans no she
doesn't like beans beans she like green
beans yeah they different than the wax
beans yeah wax beans are look like green
beans but they're yellow e no I don't
like those now what are you nuts you
serve me yellow green beans buddy it's
in the name what are you doing hey man
did you over cook these what the [__]
were these from the Moon nah give me the
ones out of the can I know them oh we
used to love them wax beans uh canned
potatoes they were great oh the little
white balls those things will knock your
we always did fresh ters bag of fresh
ters always I as I mentioned we did in
instant mashed potatoes for a long time
they make snow out of that yeah no way
just a box of and that put that on the
train set mice should be getting into
him and stuff get some W some yellow
green beans and a box of lice
please ah dinner at the Foley house dude
I remember one time my dad he had just
moved they got divorced and he cooked
dinner and dude he gave us these neon
green beans dude these things and I like
I always said I like a nice green beans
French cut I like a French cut they get
those in the can they're like all
shredded up these look like they they
were cooked at Noble dude and and all
three of us were I'm like dude we're
sitting in like a half done house
everything's like still in boxes it's
probably cold as [__] he threw out these
fluorescent green beans and I was like
no way he made it was one of those it
was like out of a sad movie he's like no
one gets up and do we I was like buddy I
got nothing but time I'd rather die at
this table than take roll the dice
eating these plutonium beans so I'm in
my
room this guy can't be Shook and I just
get out of the shower and I thought that
I'd gotten stung by a bee but I didn't
it was a fly bit me a green head it
we're not down the shore that's a bad
apartment you got there dud it was
regular I found them little got flies on
the 10th floor yeah they sneak in
through the windows cuz we don't have
any screens on the Windows sounds like a
nice place you push them out yeah I got
bit by like just was a regular fly I'm
dude I thought I got stung by a bee
that's how bad it was and I looked out
of me just a regular fly bit the [__]
out of me okay have you ever heard
anything happen what the [__] I you got
to you start this all because yeah I got
something what do you I think that's
pretty crazy it left a mark and
everything I didn't know flies could
bite I know Green heads can bite that's
a fly this was a regular fly there was
no green on it at all it was just a
regular house fly bit the [__] out of
you have sex with his wife or something
would you did you kill his buddy he's
[__] seeking Vengeance on you who
knows crazy uh-huh we'll be right
back dang this a goddamn
family no you sit in that you're a
goddamn one of the [__] you're a
great professional broadcaster you
brought the fly to the table welcome
back gang we're here for a family
episode as you know when you're when you
sign up for the patreon
there on the air screen no FES allow the
screen cut the fly vision just like 30
of us did you kill the fly I couldn't
get him too fast for you H yeah he was
too fast I had to I had the towel with
the perfect amount of water on it that's
great that's a great that's a un that's
an overlooked great weapon snap the [__]
at you I dude and I know how to use one
of those things from uh working in
kitchens you get me a bar rag a clean
bar rag with just a good amount of water
on it I will wel the [__] out of you
yeah the first time I ever realized that
I was in the bathroom and there was this
[__] fly I couldn't get and I never
see it coming I couldn't get him in the
house and then I closed the door to the
bathroom and I was like 10 and I heard
that thing huming he was you know how
they went sometimes they're in the house
for too long they get real fat and slow
dude this thing was like a tarantula
with wings he was and man I had a wet
towel fresh out of the pool that's when
you wait when they get all plump I
literally Clos the door I closed the
door said oh I'll get you you ain't
getting one of us is leaving this
[__] place Turn the Lights
Out throw a flashback I can even up the
score a little bit
yeah I couldn't get him I a couple
snapped but then he got away he was up
at the top they they crafty so now he's
still in there he's got to be dead by
now that was a few days ago how long
they live how long the flies live a
couple days that's it with all the
nutrients you have in your blubber 15 20
years I wonder if he did get a little
piece of me it hurt like hell I mean if
he bit you I'm sure is that what they're
doing now [__] flies are biting you
you trust
anybody at times like this you know geez
mosquitoes something like that I yet but
flies you got any intel on that our
internet does not seem to be functional
yeah Tudy and this goddamn bill is
jamming us the freck up jammed up at the
apartment too the game kept freezing on
me I was freaking
out folks be about a month hey dud a
month I thought it was 24 hours that's
what I always heard holy [__] now they
live down to your place
probably they can't get tiny gas masks
on no they're just all they're just all
off in themselves dude they're like I
met your parents place they're probably
swimming in the Vodka did I tell you Jes
did I tell you what Ryan D said when he
came to help me clean up my place
because I can't believe the cat hasn't
left yeah no yeah I don't I mean on the
patreon I want to do a full Deep dive in
his apartment but we can't tell him
we're coming you can't anymore it's
buttered dude I got stuff on the walls
give a we I got my I got my pictures up
in frames it looks great in there look
like the Ninja Turtles living there
video games and old Pizza do you knock
on the door Toby pops out of a sewer
what's up dudes it's just down here
Scavenging there with a big stick Pizza
dude's got 30 seconds uh all right but
this is as the big man alluded to this
is a goddamn Family episode uh and as
you know when you sign up for the
patreon we will answer your question on
the air uh we got a lot of submissions
DMS emails but I got to tell you the
patreon gets the first crack out of it
they're the homies uh so uh let's get to
it you know what I mean please um all
right let's see list is from an anonio
$10 homie never had one read is it
garbage to be named after another family
member who's alive that isn't your
father H that's rough I feel that's got
to be a slap in the Dad's face named
after
them you know what now same name is
different than being named after them I
think that's the same in context no what
but people are named after after their
grandparents all the time yeah I'm name
that to my grandfather Yeah but if it's
an uncle or something that's what I'm
saying a grandfather's a little
different grandfather's like if you're
named after like your [__]
brother-in-law or something that's tough
some some guy who's mared is Jim that's
a [__] tough look you're bad as a dad
I'd have to put my foot down just fill
just filling out the birth certificate
going we're naming them after someone
who made something of themselves hope
hopefully this name rubs off on
him I guess like I I could name he's a
successful lawyer I could name my
brother my kid after my brother I think
that's okay yeah no that's cool that
makes sense after you know an uncle
unamed after uncle but anything else is
a little wonky I always said I have
there's two cousin me and my other
cousin Kevin which I always thought was
weird in the same family how did that
come about there's just so many of us
there's there's not there's only so many
so many so many Irish so many Irish dirt
bag names you can choose from but yeah
there's only how many Joe's can one
family have there is no there is no
Joe's to be honest with you there's no
Joe's in your family no I mean my
stepfather was Joe but that was a
different family
no big with the Irish lot of we have
Brendan brendon's all right Brendan
Dennis sha Joe Dennis that's a good one
Liam Daniel that's real Irish Kevin
Michael yeah huh your whole family is
born with [__] Shamrock shoulder
tattoos dude no one has them no one it's
so crazy you would think Celtic KN or
something nothing I mean people some
people that married in got some real
Quest shout out to Brendan you give some
real questionable tattoos that's another
we have we've had multiple people with
the same Irish name move it like marry
into the family Jesus yeah a bunch of
Only God Can Judge Me running around man
yikes brother is okay so if I okay take
me say I had a kid you can name him
after your brother I'll give you that I
can name him after my brother I could
give him my mother's last my mother's
maiden name as the first name that's a
big Irish move yeah we did that we got a
lot of that we have that
um your name's oi
oion
James AO Ryan Sullivan I third how you
doing pleasure to meet
you I got a cabbie hat on those were big
in my family too oh liry McMahon
O'Reilly Jesus
Christ it's like an Irish Law
Firm when you going to get your money um
I'll go down I'll talk to him but if I
named yeah that's pretty B if I named my
kid after a cousin oh who's alive that's
weird I feel like if you're going to
name it after a family member it's got
to go your dad if it's a if it's a boy
your dad or your brother any and
especially if your brother's still Al
you know if if that's what it's saying
they're still alive if you pass for sure
that's how dirt bags honor each other I
get that that that means a lot if like
the cousin or something passed if your
cousin had passed you're like all right
I'm going to name him James after my
cousin who I loved and Jimmy Jimmy sure
uh Jimbo yeah but anything else cuz
that's just a little dude
somebody I'll even go far as this this
is the I don't know if this is uh Irish
guilt Catholic guilt dirt bag guilt
whatever it is I would feel it would be
disrespectful if I didn't name my first
born after my father or my brother that
was that was my
plan you know of course I didn't get
that PO a pod took off um understandable
sure start pulling that [__] [__] now
that' be a [__]
problem um he kissed that Christmas
present say goodbye yeah I don't
know I have no one named after me no
you're a bozo yeah gang this episode is
brought to you by better help getting
towards the end of the year holidays are
starting to come up it's the blue season
as they say yeah if you need to talk to
somebody having trouble finding a
therapist that you like reach out to
better help because they can help you
can text you can call you can do video
and you do it all from the privacy of
your own home uh yeah this uh this time
of year uh jams a lot of people up the
sunlight ain't there the whole N9 yard
season affective disorder whatever uh
talking talk therapy is a fantastic tool
if you're thinking of start of starting
therapy give better help a try better
help is totally online convenient
flexible and suited for your schedule
like the big man said you can do it by
video over the phone or even message
whatever works best for you when you get
on there you just fill out a brief
questionnaire to get match with a
license therapist and get started on
your journey that's the easiest way to
do it you're in the pool you can always
switch at no charge and find someone new
uh find your bright spot this season
with better help visit betterhelp.com
garbag today to get 10% off your first
month that's betterhelp
hp.com garbage betterhelp.com garbage do
it K let's talk about factor factor
factor America's number one ready to eat
meal kit and I'll tell you what it's the
goddamn busy season over here you're
running around you're in you got to go
here you got to go there you got to meet
this one for drinks that one for drinks
sometimes you just start grabbing stuff
do yourself a favor get on the factor
makes it makes make him about 2 minutes
get them get them on the plate ready to
go and you're eating healthy and you're
out the door save the calories for the
old a little eggn you catch my drift uh
Factor deliver Chef prepared dietitian
approved meals straight to your door
they're always fresh never Frozen like
the big man said takes two minutes you
can throw them in a microwave I throw
them on a skill little Shake around it's
fantastic choose from over 35 weekly
meal options with breakfast favorites
like apple cinnamon pancakes bacon and
cheddar egg bites shout out to an egg
Beezy uh with so many options there's
something everyone in the family will
love we've been a big uh big fan of it
for years before they were sponsors it's
fantastic everybody on the team uses
them with vegan vegetarian keto calorie
Smart Plus protein meal options no
matter what your goal is Factor can be
there to help you head toctor meals.com
garbage 50 and use code garbage 50 to
get 50% off that's Cod garbage 5@ Factor
meals.com garbage to get 50% off to it
growing up how often would your mom call
you the wrong name no now now I get it
my sister calls me my nephew's name
it'll be like Billy Jimmy Johnny Kevin
yeah yeah that's it's like I do that
[__] now too with the kids I don't know
who the [__] what's going on we we had a
dog with a Teena my brother has a tavish
as a tame and then I Toby my mom would
go it would go dog my brother then me
every time all Jesus the dog's getting
top dilling at your crib that's up dude
you stink if the dog the dog's name
trible sounds like he has chamia where
where does Toby come from uh they wanted
I we talked about this they wanted to
call me they wanted to call me Toby but
they thought if I was going to be like a
business guy itd look dumb on a plaque
or a door boy were they
wrong that's this guy yeah Toby yeah I
wouldn't at Toby I wouldn't get anything
from Toby Toby would Toby's not closing
the deal Toby's showing up late to the
meeting I close deals I show up late to
meetings yeah but you they they they
were right with that foresight if your
name would just would have been Toby
McMullen yeah yeah no I don't think so
yeah Thomas ain't much better though no
what are you talking about Thomas thas
is a strong name has there been any
presiden thas MC Thomas McMullen Law
Firm Thomas McMullen accounting Dr
Thomas McMullen I'll tell you who's not
doing my uh endoscopy it's Toby McMullen
yeah Toby McMullen runs a sticker
Emporium yeah you're not you're not
running the gas when I get my
colonoscopy I'll tell you that that's
who is running the gas you wanted Toby
little [__] you want to Toby a little
heavy-handed with the haha
juice I told I had to tell the guy when
I got my angiogram I had to tell him to
tweak it up a little bit Yeah the tanks
you're dealing with a dealing with a
seasoned vet here buddy Budd I ain't no
bubblegummer yeah tanks are light when I
clock out I brought my own I can't heav
here oh that's a cute one you pull out a
three-footer
dude big balloon right before you go oh
man I saw a great video of this guy
running around a music festival with
balloons full of helium instead of nitr
dick that's a good time you then got to
give him the was he charging them he
goes that first one's free a that's fun
what a dick good clean F these dirt
these dirt back iies are just huffing it
and they just go this this really so mad
it's great I would uh that was big back
in the day that was like my first foray
into drug use balloons getting your hand
D we would go to a party supply and just
buy helium balloons for like a dollar
or2 dollar just Huff them when we were
like eight really yeah shout out to
party land why cuz we were bored they
didn't [__] you up no just made your
voice High yeah I mean it was Jesus
Christ even I didn't do that [__]
smoking candied cigarettes and stuff do
you remember I think we talked they had
the the gum cigarettes obviously but
then they used to just sell fake heaters
and they had like a little tin foil like
red tin foil on the end of it they and
they just blew smoke it wasn't candy it
wasn't gum oh know you're they sold them
in two packs and we'd go there I'd get a
pack of heaters and a couple of balloons
for the boys and we would just hang out
in a parking lot I mean we looked like
looked like we were tailgating fish
there was the thin ones that were that
were just candy they were almost like
sweet sugarcan time yeah they sucked the
bubblegum one sucked you got that first
puff puff with that first puff was was
good but then they had these fake Philip
Mo somebody had to behind those things
they Ed those in like school plays a lot
ah that makes
sense yeah I was that's so crazy what to
have a school play with the kids are
smoking that's insane doing 12 Angry Men
yeah what's going on here dude my high
school didn't ban smoking the year
before I got there like on campus
heaters yeah that's crazy oh yeah we
weren't allowed to have them on the
property so like stand across the street
like a dirt bag no I mean you couldn't
we couldn't walk to school but like you
would definitely get in your car if you
had like a if you were staying after you
had like 10 minutes to get there you
could run down get in your car [__]
bust a loop grab a heater and come in
like you smell like smoke my mother
smokes she's the single mother with a
hard shout out to flip that's a flip
line they took him in to smell him into
the principal's office he goes my M they
go you smell like smoke goes my mother
smokes that's all right all right let's
see here $10 hogy shout out which is a
new name I love shout out to the $10
hogies um is it garbage the first time
you meet your wife's extended family one
of her cousins only only ask you
questions about the size of your hog
because of how tall you
are that's pretty good you show up to
[__] a birthday party I was like you
got F you got beat on you huh you
probably look at this so here
oh than God I assumed it was a chick
like I don't get over here let me take a
look at that
thing the family tradition you got to
bust it out new guys got to show it step
right over here young mans it's
painfully
average oh man usually see Kenya dunk or
you know something like that you
probably got a [__] on you don't you
he's just going now the hype makes it
worse actually proportionately it looks
smaller than the average guy walking
around
on you it'd be great on me it's a
tragedy a that's tough ah yeah that is a
that is a sure dirt bag sign too of
anybody tall gets put into a new
environment where there's no tall people
the laundry list of [__] Bo my mom
asked my buddy my buddy every single
time can I blow you how dare you she
smoked uhuh
um every time she said did you get
taller every single time everying single
time that was a big thing too between
like uh junior high especially like when
everybody's like hitting puberty and
stuff
MH parents loved gauging how much you
grew if you hadn't seen someone in like
3 six months or over the summer you must
have shut up about 3 feet what are they
feeding you they got a bunch of dad
jokes for you what's that dingling
like well we hit the pool see what's
up uh all right let's see here this is
from a dirty sock is it garbage if your
brother is dating your girlfriend's mom
is it garbage if your brother is dating
your girlfriend's mom how much older is
your
brother Pro it says it's West Virginia
so probably not that it's either it's a
younger mom who knows though West
Virginia is its own things are a little
different these days though all right
say you got say okay say you're in high
school you're dating girl at 17 you got
a brother that's 24
25 and maybe the she's 32 maybe the mom
no 32 that's 17 how how what's the
difference 16 let's say 20 she's 37 okay
all right let's say you had she had the
kid when she was
20 you know it's kind of a thing now
maybe in the videos you're watching what
are you talk kind of you're really
spinning the you're really pushing this
on us huh that's kind of a thing I'm
into right now those cougars are out
there what are you talking about that's
they're living their lives baby they're
not waiting I assume it's a coug they're
having a good time I tell you what God
damn it God bless them I assume it's A
coug Sitch they got going on over there
which I'm fine with but it's just like
the awkwardness to me is too much
there's no awkward what awkward what's
awkward what's awkward that's got to be
awkward for the girl to be like your
brother's having sex with my mom sure
I'll give you that okay so yeah that's
the awkwardness fair enough yeah the you
know the brother the two kids who cares
all funny games baby
talk about taking over families fully
infiltrated probably on the goddamn will
now if you're the ex-husband or the
father you probably don't like that too
much that's got to be a kick in the
wiener but maybe he's dating some young
broad he's doing his thing everybody's
happy there you go biasly that's a
little allowed unfortunately with the
what do you mean the standards and
practices of
society that's what I'm saying that
shit's all switched up now I don't think
so it's definitely Mama's got to have
her fun too it's in Baby Bo I'm not
saying shout out to V RS I'm not saying
she right y I'm not saying she doesn't
I'm just saying you ever seen that movie
no what oh go home immediately and do
yourself a favor and put on baby boy
fantastic film classic there's a there's
a spot in Chicago with a bunch of
downtown it's called the Viagra Triangle
it's this one section where Rush
intersects with another Street there's
this triangle of bars where all these
business dudes hang out right and the
amount of times my boys would be like
we're going to the Viagra Triangle were
getting some cougars uh and then would
come back striking out with 40-year-old
ladies dude oh yeah yeah bunch of
[__] Open Mic or bike messeng get L
there dude in [__] Gap button wrinkly
Gap button Downs sure they're sharing
they're going to the bathroom coming out
allor right excuse me yeah that ain't
the way that works yeah hell honey talks
baby yeah that you always think you're
there's there's always someone better if
you're like oh we're going here we're
each
the chicks are going to lap us up it's
like nah there's way better looking way
more successful cooler dudes oh yeah
always yeah never thought I had a shot
no no want to check out my Lumina out
front it's a 96 me and my brother me and
my brother Shar
it yeah I pull up in the Dodge 600 Turbo
with the dent in the door yeah looking
to close I never had anything cool the
passenger door don't open you got to
climb through the driver
side this thing is roof is hanging down
yeah I got to get the felt fixed sorry
about that this is my beater there's a
staple gun around here
somewhere keep balloons in there to keep
it up yeah I never I never had anything
that's a very Whimsical solution Hank
mhm what oh
balloons I'm on my way to aardi after
this people know you're a good time
they're filled with heal if you want to
rip one it's up to you I think I got
some fake sigs laying around you want to
come back to my
place you come be
rupted uh I never had anything cool that
would like I never had a nice call like
no I had no external assets no to make
me in a better position no to try to
close a deal I had never had a cool
place never had a cool
never had a cool wardrobe never I mean I
was a fat piece of [__] I never like
there was nothing of like ah I can just
throw on a they were like your
good-looking friends would be doing [__]
like that he models in the summer or
something like that he'd go in there and
you know pull an older broad out of yeah
it wasn't the same for me look like I
was there to fix the ice
machine it's my brother Kevin hey hey
what's up I'll be over
here man I'm here to fix the HVAC and
provide disappointing
sex you can do both of those I remember
one time me and my buddy were were at uh
like we were we were hanging out with
this girl that he was like friends with
and we all ended up back at her place
hanging out whatever uh drinking and it
was like you know which one was going to
try to like make the move or whatever
and it was clearly him so I just sat
there on the couch oh God he was my ride
home [__] sitting there playing with
the dog like an idiot
you're you're fighting over a bone in
your
mouth you got the other end of the
rope that was embarrassing yeah there
but he was like a tall good-looking I
know yeah I know I know and I was me I
never even wanted to do like does she
have a friend cuz I'm like she does she
have a friend who looks like me you
think I'm going to call somebody up
that's not
there hey quick do your hair real quick
I I got a four over here bruis who's
breathing out of his
mouth you have lettuce on your
shirt that's buddy I wasn't eating
lettuce back
then barbecue sauce maybe you got some
other chicks you can call you got any
you got any you got any friends around
here you got like the
party I'm over there playing beer pong
by
myself you got a big tog go coffee in
your hand you got your own creamer
here a man now you kids have fun I'll be
with the
dog god man she had no TV either I was
just sitting there like an
[__] got a book I can read you guys
subscribed to that Geo or something
Reading 50 Shades of Gray and all
chubbed
[Music]
up
God oh man that's all right um all right
let's see here
uh this this is from disappointing salad
is it garbage if you leave to smoke a
Sig right before the check comes my
mother-in-law is a master at it and is
never paid once it's crazy I I mean if
we know a guy who that pulls a similar
move but not related to the check huh
yeah likes to disappeared oh Mr
McMuffins it was you McMuffin Thomas
that's a Toby move Thomas stays in
Thomas Thomas staves and pick up picks
up the check I does anybody really do
that like is that really why she gets up
I'm sure I mean I would feel like such a
like a dirt I well here's my thing I
think if you just Embrace that and you
own it and you go this is the kind of
person I am I don't have any sh some
people just don't have that's the point
of Shame hold on I always assumed that
okay say
uh the three of us went
out together uhhuh okay we got you got
the birds and all that kind of stuff we
we all go out Toby picks up to check one
time you pick up to check one time I
don't pick up to check you know I run I
go to the bathroom and pretend to be you
know having a smoke or whatever sure the
next time we go out wouldn't you be like
how long can you get away with that she
gets up and goes catches it well here
all right so it's the Mother-in-law so I
assume it's him but she's not p
I know but I mean at every time you
you'd even look to be like gra [__]
make you know make a grab for it make a
move for I don't know pick up one out of
every 50 I don't know a situation where
the Mother-in-law would be expected to
pay at at a
dinner do you no but I I think the fact
that she gets up every time right before
the check comes he should tell her
listen you you don't got to pay hang
out no but I do as also you have to step
outside of this and live in the world
where you are really crazy me that would
bother you at some point it for sure I
just like yeah sure in a perfect thing
yeah your mother-in-law never pays but
the act of like never even reaching once
nothing the fact you're going to lie and
go I got this is perfect time for a guy
I get that would bother me a guy I
get I thought we were past those
societal Norms of men and women I just
said everybody was [__] I still pay
for a lady's
dinner I'm just saying moms are like to
get theirs a for D I'm a goddamn
gentleman after all sure no I but I I I
do get the the blat and I I think what
would bother me in this situation is
that the person man woman whoever it
doesn't matter thinks they're getting
away with it Ah that's what would bother
me of like you think I don't know what
the [__] you're doing here lady have the
check waiting at their seat when they
come back yeah oh yeah it's for you oh
no we haven't squared up yet do you have
your card and also too she thinks I
would assume it's the Mother-in-law she
thinks she's doing it cuz there is is no
next time she's always probably the
fifth wheel so everybody gets just gets
collected you know what I mean she just
keeps getting swept under the roow she's
like a kid which hey I respect and and
any I respect the scam if that's the
scam you want to run I got to go catch a
heater I'm with it I like the hustle
yeah I gotta you know I gotta I would be
more grossed out and I don't know if I I
know in the past I have uh going out to
smoke in between the meal is gross I've
said you said this is fine yeah I've
always been I've turned on it I come
from a long line of smokers and no one
ever left the once they stop smoking
during you could stop smoking at the
table you never left the table to go
catch a heater but you know what was
nice back in the day before the table
was ready if the if the party was at the
bar I got a Shirley tea in my hand
relaxing a little bit chilling you
know and then maybe some aunts or some
uncles at the okay the table's right
that yeah that's different oh we're
going to pop out you go get seated table
you show up to the table just wreaking I
don't know how we did it disgusting I
was I dude I was like I said predisposed
to be a [__] guy on heaters every
male in my life smokes sigs at the table
in the call like TR true if you smoke
your kids are going to smoke right there
what are the can you look up the the the
the numbers on that it's no good it
ain't good if you're a SM or your kids
are going to smoke man that's no way no
that's like I know a lot of a lot of
people in my family hide it from their
kids which I respect I respect it uhuh
plus it makes it a little funner yeah go
out there you do that you do the hand
got
heat how you go out Patty's going to see
us I'm ducking behind work vans and [__]
in the driveway [__] rolling under a
Suburban it's taking a trash out yep
teenagers are much more likely to smoke
and be dependent on nicotine if parents
are dependent on nicotine hit me up yeah
none of that yeah you got to hide it
from hide it from the kids out you first
of all you should get off the heaters
they're not good my S included I feel
like we used to hide a lot more from the
kids that's how you did it now
everybody's talking in front of the kids
about things that are going on all that
kind of stuff then they're regurgitating
that [__] yeah hide it from the kids MH
Paul Simon it's one of the lyrics it's
true I was talking to like an
eight-year-old the other day and he was
telling me that everybody's banging
cougars these say she's got the internet
this G it's wild sorry kid knows what's
going on St to date on current
affairs uh all right let's see here um
all right this is from Fred uh $10 home
in here never had one read is a garbage
to trade a big container of orange
chicken for an eighth of weed after you
finish your shift at Panda Express that
is such a good trade dude my plug played
ball he said yeah so he's trading he's
working his right right he he is running
the risk of maybe getting knocked did
you take an entree you didn't I'm sure
you're allowed to take something I I
understand I'm just saying and let me
tell you something that Panda Express
ain't no [__] joke I don't think I
ever had it woo
delicious are they we I feel like they
just got popular nah they they've been
popular for a while little real it's a
big food was a big food court thing our
food courts were always like the Teryaki
crazy or something like started moving
in no but these organized the ones they
were Standalone all the the all the
Asian ones in nor were Standalone there
was no like corporate and what I'm
telling you is that they started to move
in yeah yeah I'm just saying I never uh
I understand what you're saying I'm just
saying I never I never seen I never had
the opportunity really plus I always
thought that they were more high-end
weren't they Panda Express no no not
like like a Benny Hana no stop the
chicken's good no you're thinking of
what PF Changs ah yes I'm thinking of PF
CH Express is like a take I like Got
Annie Panda Express is good though it is
but it's just pure sugar sure it's just
chicken nuggets with sugar yeah let's
get some I mean I'm not complaining I'm
just saying 33 years old I got to tell
you we paid a rent what are you nuts
yeah goddamn right is sugar yeah no PF
Changs is a t i mean that joint I might
as well been [__] yeah the you know
prime minister of China's place that
place [__] seem [__] hoyy toyy
you're pulling up with little American
flags on your car the delegate from
[__] bozo lands
here grab a heater I'm going right in
stall them for me will you sir you can't
park here I got Di
Community I seen Law and
Order oh man all right all right let's
see here this is from Nick have you ever
purchased a championship wrestling
belt as a kid yeah I mean wrestling was
I I couldn't have been more into
wrestling as a kid ww it was the the
height of WCW WWF Monday Night Raw and I
guess it was Nitro maybe they had
Mondays and then Wednesday Thursday I
think and the Wrestlemania woo man was
huge a big deal Stone Cold Steve Austin
Hulk was still banging Hulk was in WCW
wasn't he uh he started WWF then he went
to and I think at one point he started
in WWF I know that that was a huge hul I
was I was in Hulk Mania as it happened
he then went to WCW and he became
Hollywood H Hollywood yeah he turned
heel a little bit he came the Blackbeard
and the that was
NWO uh yeah New World Order woo shout
out to the wolf pack DX everybody that
was like
that was dude he went bad it was dude we
were in sixth grade when sucket came out
oh
man dude [__] telling te say Hey
Kevin sit down
suck I'd hit him with a toot sweet man
that lasted for about three days before
they got on that and then you weren't
allowed to do this right this was suck
it but you could do this because we were
like you could do that was the the
Degeneration X was like I'm doing my
then they caught window that and they
were like all right no more no more gang
symbols I tell you when I was in fourth
grade that I I did that to to the class
I grabbed my crotch and then they told
Patty on me I've had to have told you
this no yeah you know what I'm talking
about oh yeah a dude it was you want to
grab you a little wiener why don't you
get over here and I'll grab it for you
dude I was how big is that hog of yours
I did that they were like all right
you're going to the principal's office
teer got me outside she's like I swear
to God you do one more thing today I'm
I'm I'm taking it I'm calling your
mother I'm like all yeah sure couple
periods later we were doing the jump in
the hallway where you hit the drop
ceilings and like knock them out of
place got busted for that call when I
get home from school she's like you were
hitting drop ceilings in school whatever
sorry whatever I got in trouble hours go
by dinner maybe an episode of
Moonlighting I'm upstairs getting in my
tubby out of nowhere up in waterboard
you I don't know dude I'm completely
naked about to get into the tub the door
gets kicked open Patty grabs her crotch
she's like and whoever taught you this I
don't ever want to see him in this house
again like dude the worst night ever man
your mom grabbing on her hooa
yikes what a [__] scene oh
man about haven't been hard
since
po I was about to do my business in the
dtive had the candles going and
everything comes in and jams me
up I so I told I did tell you about it
oh yeah never bought a championship belt
because those aren't bought those are
earned yeah uh we would buy them like
there was like the toy version you could
get for like you know 15 bucks or
whatever then there was like the higher
end like actual metal or something but
we I mean we were also like I think this
was like fourth grade when [__] Stone
Cold Steve Austin they had to have
plastic ones you could buy toys that's
what I'm saying yeah they were like 14
bucks or you know 19 bucks or whatever
so like everybody had one of those your
buddies in the face with it oh man
coming off the Turn Style with it a good
days we were big wrestlers shout out to
Crying Ryan that was my name I got that
was my move I got sunned out of being a
wrestling fan how pulled up to like
fourth grade North Carolina all the all
the other kids are talking about
wrestling I was like I'll watch watched
one night came back the next day and I
was like oh man that was crazy that
Stone Cold Steve angles the man and some
oh my some kid some kid was like you
ain't no real wrestling fan Stone Cold
Steve Ang to's watching college
wrestling Ohio really gave it to Penn
State yesterday some hillbilly really
put me in my place watching the
Olympics you guys want to practice
fireman's carries dork get a folding
chair to your face that's why probably
why you got sent off to that school um
got you out of there we had I what was
your public what was your public school
would have been like down there probably
not great oh real bad lot of meth yeah
lot of meth sounds pretty cool to me we
say no wrestling good work if you can
get it um there was the year so I was
big into wrestling and then like this
had to be like third fourth grade or
whatever and there was remember the man
it's tough to put into words you know
how like you'd go over to your friend's
house who was like it was a driveway it
wasn't my neighborhood it was like I'd
have to get dropped off in my budd's
house and he had such a tight
neighborhood of people right like there
was like older there was kids that were
like and they all comingled real well
mine didn't cuz like my street was like
added on to my neigh that kid what you
were that kid that showed up well no we
were good all yeah all through like up
until about 10 and then it was all kids
my brother's age so they got all older
you know what I mean like I thought flip
and Pat lived in your neighborhood
though no I'd go to their neighborhood
my neighborhood didn't have kids my age
at one point they did but then like it
all just kind of phased out that sucks I
know that's weird um we had Town Line we
had [__] everybody yeah they'd come
to us even even the nicer neighborhoods
you're in a [__] townhouse Community
you're in there like [__] rats
there's probably nine guys to a nine
families to a house in there no [__]
it's a good time parents are [__] you
know probably practicing their wrestling
moves and stuff no one's watching you
guys there was easily 50 kids from let's
say 4th grade to 12th grade it was
awesome um one moment Shipp out of us in
my uh in my my wrestling that changed
forever how I see
wrestling of it was like fun you're like
oh this is cool it's fake but kind of
real who you know was still this is way
pre- internet so you're like what is
real what is f you know all that kind of
stuff there was no the bubble hadn't
nationally burst yet you know what I
mean it's still real to me man still
real to me those guys are out there I
love when they call someone on it
they're you think this is fake and they
[__] sucker punch the reporter or
whatever is this feel fake like God damn
um but there was a so one of the there
was a group of us my age and then a
couple years older was my buddy's
brother and like his crew you know what
I mean but they were all within like
three years of each other or whatever
okay and then there was an older guy
Mark who was is a little just rubbed
just a weird guy we were all like
skateboarding playing sports how old are
you 10 he's probably 17 18 and he would
just come out he lived like on the side
of the street so he would come out and
just like talk to us or whatever nothing
like weird or just like and he's like
guys listen there was like a DAT line
NBC like expose on wrestling that night
and he's like I don't want anybody like
came out like we were in like a
semicircle and he like everybody gather
no one watch this it's going going to
pop the bubble it's going to take take
away what we love and I was like buddy
you are into this way too deep you go
get laid or something [__] out here
talking to out here talking to Children
about wrestling buddy what the [__] go
[__] go go look at porn go get a
nudie mag something we get that job at
the grocery store what the kick rocks
dude I remember being like everybody's
like okay I'm like [__] somebody pass
me a light I'm [__] out of here here
I'm watching dat line yeah cup of coffee
uh yeah it was just one of those he was
one of those kids where you're like the
house looked different than the rest of
the street like every there was
something off un kept unkempt just
socially everything there was something
a little off about that house everybody
knew it the kind of house that cut their
own grass but did it really bad did it
shitty like once every 3 weeks and
didn't get the trimmer out they were
just running and gunning even looked
even worse I know it's like Let It All
grow with the dandel dude think you're
on vacation at least yeah yeah it was
one of those I remember I was like oh
man I was like I can never fully get in
I I was like I never want to be that guy
so I have to stop believing that this is
real now I never want to be calling the
[__] neighborhood kids over to talk
to them hey do you see do you see stone
cold last night all right this is from
Dalton never had one read is it garbage
if your dad was the customer of month
the customer of the month 6 months in a
row at Rena Center simply for paying his
bill on time every month they used to
take his picture and hang it up on the
behind the register to show all the
other dirt bags what king dirt bag was
love yous ouch that's one thing I've
never ful and we've talked about it I've
never fully understood you never went in
there I don't think so never went in
there uh-uh we did I don't understand it
I mean like our furniture wasn't we had
the same couches for like well over a
decade like my whole childhood they were
the same couches and then when I
probably like junior high or something
maybe even high school she got no like
I'm not sitting here from a place of
like we had nice furniture but that
never renting a couch don't ever make
sense to nobody we went in there I'll
never forget it was a Saturday afternoon
we went in there to look for an
entertainment center I don't know if
they were just checking out what was
available they like what fers you owe us
n Grand you haven't paid off that Lazy
Boy yet I knew even as I was probably 11
or 12 I knew there was something wrong
walking in there why because everybody's
missing
fingers I thought I was about to quit
school and get a job start earning my
key yeah y'all hiring yeah dude I was
like oh we're jamed up Mom we're jammed
up ain't we what's a couch go for can
like the rent can you look that up like
I don't it's like a couple bucks a month
it's for people bucks no it's for people
who don't have liquid cash Endor credit
cards right right I don't
know what is rent Center are they still
in business yeah they're booming Sha Sha
bumps them R the center I'm pretty sure
no he doesn't that's Ring cameras no
Papa John's
too what do you got T-Bone give me one
second
there
ah Rena Center provides new and used
brand name Furniture appliances
computers electronics for Brands such as
okay as part of the rent to own business
model Rena Center generally makes items
available with small initial payments
and no long-term
obligations so what does that mean you
you just bring it back I think they take
it back you still paying I don't think
it's returned necessarily I think it's
taken rent to own I guess I kind of get
but they have like Wayfair now you can
just do payment plans yeah yeah so I
figured they'd be eating their business
anywhere from 20 to 40 bucks a week a
week a week that's how they do it a week
oh yeah you're hurting that's nuts
man
yikes that's bad news it's a real good
way to pay 18 grand for a couch yeah
right that's two grand a year how much
is a give me how much do a couch at Rent
A Center that's what I just told you no
does it say the total price or you just
keep doing
that I don't know the it's probably like
forever like what's the what's the
whatever till you own it 99 payments of
$34.99 a week we'll get you a signature
design Ashley Balan slow three-piece
sectional with Shay's Lounge that's
probably not that bad because just say
it's a 100 that comes out to four grand
right 39 bucks times 100 is $3,900 yeah
it's
3,4 total cost down 3400 same as cash
but the C but they're saying the cash
price is, 1500 so you're going to wind
you're going to pay double if you rent H
so that's only 1,500 and they're
charging you 32 man this country get you
coming and going [__] dude people are
already jammed up you're jamming them up
for good too and also I'm pretty sure a
renaer doesn't build your
credit no yeah I don't think it can only
hurt like you're not like well I've made
I made every payment I haven't missed a
payment it don't affect me going sir a
couch is not an
[Laughter]
asset uh yeah that's [__] up that's
[__] up I guess you got to do it if
you got to do it but like I would argue
like there's got go to Craigslist and
buy a $200 couch they didn't we didn't
have that [__] we would went to
Craigslist I get I get then we were
jammed up Penny Saver then I get then
but something they're classifi people
are moving people used to move there was
classifi before Craigslist the neighbor
go to drive to a [__] garage
sale I don't I mean that's crazy we were
there looking for an entertainment
center huh about getting a little work
done huh sitting around yeah you two are
slacking over here let's go uh I don't
know we had one we had one entertainment
center my dad got that was way too big
for the first apartment we were living
in our townhouse we were like he got man
and we moved that thing for he probably
still has it for 25 years dude
everywhere we every time he moved which
was a lot by the way [__] loading
humping that thing in the back of a
pickup truck yeah we had a sweet one big
TV put in there we had the TV then these
two up here were glass oh top half it's
like the two putting those glass doors
in my dad after like nine cores light
felt like a Glazer freaking out yeah um
then we had the two yeah and we had like
the VHS the whole nine CD player in
there dog I have been dying to get my
hands on an old school like CRT Square
TV and a VHS player just cuz I want to
see what the quality was like like yeah
cuz in my cuz it was like a movie
theater in my head put your videos on
sicko little lusted SE gold
school what like Top Gun and stuff no
Ferris spers day off no yeah right
gazungas 3 talking about heinfeld you
know that
one that was in the back of West Coast
Video shout out to it peeking around the
door like Kramer with the big
hair God all right we got to wrap it up
gang gang we love you to death grab
tickets for that Philly show mhm get
over to the patreon yeah we're all over
the road shows are selling out get them
tickets it's a good freaking time I tell
you see you next week peace peace